autour des contes de noël il ya deux
positionnements possible sur les contes
de noël bourgeois on a envie de les voir
soit on n'a pas envie de les voir
mais dans les deux cas généralement ce
qu'on regarde la télévision c'est une
bonne dose globale
donc on vous a fait un petit récap n'y a
pas de chef-d'oeuvre là dedans mais ça
c'est tendre ça détend un ace christmas
time
oui nous sommes reconçu les oui il fait
nuit à 17h oui il fait froid sur toute
une partie de la france
oui on ne fait que manger mais comme un
phare dans la nuit les téléfilms de noël
nous sauf de notre naufrage collectif
[Musique]
ces comptes qui envahissent nos écrans
depuis lundi qu'ils sont si réconfortant
des histoires improbables des pulls avec
trop de couleurs des père noël mal
doublés en français
bref le programme idéal pour traîner sur
son canapé sous son plaid vraiment
génial ces programmes sont chaque année
un rendez vous que les français
plébiscitent avec le confinement ses
programmes cartonne encore plus que
d'habitude comme le confirme jonathan et
scarpia d'eau adjoint la directrice des
acquisitions de tf1
les audiences peuvent s'envoler à des
niveaux qu'on ne peut quasiment pas
observé pendant l'année en après midi
alors on oublie un temps l'enfer du
corona et on se concentre sur père noël
incognito ou encore coup de foudre sur
une mélodie de l'ol
je te souhaite un joyeux noël moi aussi
je te souhaite un joyeux noël
[Musique]
alors il y en a qui sont très content de
ce retour des contes de noël
d'autres beaucoup moins alors alors
ylvanie non ça non alors pourtant noël
c'est ma période préférée de l'année
mais là je n'en peuvent plus c'est
toujours la même histoire c'est il se
rend compte
ils se détestent ils vont être obligés
de passer noël ensemble et là d'un coup
c'est le grand amour
ils vont s'aimer ils ont beaucoup donné
mais là il est toujours la même histoire
et l arrêt très bonne est dans une
période où l anis et le co vide il ya
les attend c'est terrible et je vais
d'ailleurs non moi je sais pas comment
vous vous le vivez même toit jamais
quand on regarde ses films chez désolé
ça donne un peu de un peu de gaieté
alors oui c'est simple c'est ces
potaches ou quoi mais changer de
scénario mais ça te donne de dollars aux
r&d maman j'ai raté l'avion l'airpass
pendant les périodes de noël
je le sais c'est bien ça à égayer un peu
tout le monde il faut non sa change elle
aussi
fall a croqué divine mais oui la jambe à
ça je le rejoins c'est vrai que
d'habitude je n'ai pas forcément une fan
mais j'avoue cette année mon avis a
changé parce que ça y est on respire on
sourit peut-être oui c'est un peu cucul
je pense que beaucoup vont le dire mais
là où lui qu on sera franchement si on
n'en peut plus du matin au soir les
chaînes d'info le colis les attentats
enfin la stoppe donc là oui ça fait du
bien ça joue sur les audiences sur tf1
un million cette filiale à béziers pour
les deux chine qui se sont suivies en
revanche sur m6 et 112 milles ça marche
un peu moins bien mais globalement oui
c'est sûr qu'on va voir des contes de
noël jusqu'à noël tous les jours et ça
se fait tous les jours ils ont dû racler
des fonds de cuve là
j'aime bien ça c'est bien c'est bien ça
mais oui on a envie d'avoir d'avoir une
vie de voir une vie qu'on n'aura jamais
au bout de cinq minutes se sont écoulées
conte de noël ainsi que jean décotte
alors vous vous êtes un peu moi je
faisais un peu déprimant sont déprimés
mais j'aimerais juste vous dire le plus
on évolue - ya de création et et je suis
désolé mais là on se reprend encore des
rediffusions wave une époque sept ans
vous aviez le choix pour plein
d'émission en deuxième partie de soirée
de débat vous aviez ça se discute vous
alliez de la rue des leçons vous aviez
plein de gens vous pouviez retrouver en
deuxième partie de soirée mais on n'y a
plus rien et l'allongement des moyens il
faut vous dire un truc mon rendez vous
du jeudi balances ton pass m'a manqué
hier à oui parce qu'ils avaient pas
d'émission il ya plus d'émissions de
débat
[Rires]
je dis cela dit je vous dire c'est qu'à
un moment donné j'ai peut-être je suis
peut-être un vieux compte 50 ans mais ce
que je vois à témoin ses du débat c'est
de l' échange ses amis des trucs
aujourd'hui moi je n'ai pas du tout
envie de maintenant ça ne regarde que
moi j'ai pas du tout envie de voir ça on
les a vus arriver
cette fois c'est toujours la même chose
qu'on conclut qu je suis totalement
d'accord avec vous donc je suis déçu il
attend autre chose aujourd'hui de la
télévision donc ce sont des succès
d'apple mois des succès par défaut parce
qu'il ya plus rien d'autre à viser l'or
comme d'habitude magali bernaquez votre
contradictrice oui ça sert et adore les
contes de noël que je t'aime non en vrai
je suis totalement d'accord avec toi
mais c'est pas de sujet parce que le
problème que tian trop bien oui oui le
problème que tu es en train d'exploser
en ce moment c'est un problème qui passe
à l'année c'est à dire qu'en fait chaque
année en ce moment tout le temps qu vide
ou paco ville ce que tu dis les
émissions débats ça manque n'ya que
balances ton post est pourquoi benjamin
il se moque de moi quand j entends je
fais rien d'autre à dire quelque chose
de très intelligent
je suis là et qu'elle me voit comme
nicolas
que tu dis tu as raison mais c'est toute
l'année c'est le problème de la télé
aujourd'hui oui bien sûr c'est pas de
problème dans ce moment en ce moment oui
on a besoin de conte de fées on a besoin
de noël on a voulu me descendre parce
que la paire effet mais tu as raison on
manque aussi de déjà se balancent ton
post il n'y en a plus c'est dommage
excusez moi mais on est des gens actifs
se pensant un petit peu aux gens un peu
moins actifs qui sont chez eux l'après
midi un plein un bon chocolat chaud
ayew je rappelle qu'en mai même si on
est en confinement on est quand même
sens et à bosser à la maison parce que
les longtemps un plaid et des chocolats
bouffer c'est pas la majorité mais en
face nos journées à bouffer des
chocolats d'habiter oui voilà ça c'est
que ça s'adresse à un public très la
petite mercy
la preuve c'est que dans les danses et
téléfilms ya dolly parton qui était une
star de la country galère des années 60
noyait ça s'adresse à un public
particulier
on négocie on a connu sans ces satanés
20 ans alors je les vignes vingt ans
juste au delà san nicola je suis pas
d'accord avec toi en plus toi qui est
producteur d'émissions tu le sais
aujourd'hui produire des émissions c'est
très compliqué l'on vient de parler
d'une émission nouvelles sur france 2 tu
n'aimes pas l'émission de julien courbet
sur m6 elle ne fonctionne pas très bien
joué donc un moment donné la création
aujourd'hui est très compliqué tu le
sais moi pour bosser aussi en production
aujourd'hui les chaînes ont gelé les
budgets on ne peut pas créer 10
l'audience elle est là une chaîne ne va
pas créer pour perd de l'argent ça fait
rire les gens sous le pont de 9 et 1
million 7 l'après midi donc c'est con
mais il avoue nicolas propose de vous
dire que le premier set il a coûté vingt
mille balles de débreak l'eau ça
correspond à des conseils généraux
achetez vous des petits chocolats
les belles allées on va avancer